electric cars
despite the subsidization and lobbying
how much subsidization to the point
where
my wife wanted to get a tesla not
because we were not because we wanted a
tesla because she wanted a self-driving
car
don't buy a new car it's the same ever
it is better for you to buy
an old 85 bronco than that new tesla
first off i don't want a tesla sorry tim
from hr i don't like them right now
the many of you have asked me uh this
have you ever changed your mind or
anything and to be clear
that's not real the reason for change my
mind is to present your position
in the affirmative and allow other
people to make an argument and that's
because a lot of people are busy trying
to score
points and the idea for change of mind
is to listen to someone
make their case that being said uh i
have changed my mind
on a subject really ah
tesla's let's go
[Music]
well okay let me be really clear here uh
i have spoken in the past
about uh how this is where that montage
would come in handy where
right i wasn't a big fan of electric
cars teslas in general now let me be
really clear
where i have not changed my mind a lot
of traffic arguments
the arguments still stand in that
electric cars are not better for the
environment than buying a used car
okay the best thing you can do is buy a
used beater and drive it into the ground
you don't need a new tesla
and if you go and you look at these
lithium-ion batteries depending which
ones they are
mining for these very difficult to put
together minerals
and they're they basically sit in the
earth for a very long time
right now it is and by the way your
electricity comes from somewhere
cool some places that's that's kind of
that's reductive
sorry but clean coat it does typically
where does your energy come from where
you are
it could come from gas natural gas it
could come from coal
uh in quebec it came from hydroelectric
which is apparently a problem here
because of an endangered species of fish
i don't get it it's just water moving
you saw swiss family robinson i don't
know how anyone's against it
now i am also still against subsidies
in general i want to be really clear and
there it has been a lot of subsidization
for electric cars and yes
tesla is a company that would not exist
if not forcep my mind has not
changed on that also i still maintain
that most electric cars
this is where there's an exception
tesla's not withstanding but most
electric cars
are still pretty gay so okay
uh by the way hit the notification bell
if you want more of this uh because
every morning you know you get a
notification now
if you were ever worried about us being
able to do youtube
yeah it's the time to sign up for mud
club let me be really clear here because
when i had to reflect upon all of this
right tesla is basically an
american-based car man right
yeah we have to compare them to the
marketplace now tesla has received
directly 0.4 billion dollars in
subsidies okay
not a big fan of that but they did pay
it all back
early with interest so now if we compare
that to
the big three right gm chrysler ford
they received just in 2008 and that's
not the first bailout
80 billion dollars alone and the
taxpayers still on the hook for nine
billion of those dollars so that's more
80 billion there's a gap there compared
to 9 billion i do think this is
important because
the bailout was given to the big three
american car companies
when they were losing market share
because they had mismanaged their
businesses they had these crazy union
pensions whereas tesla received these
subsidies while they were creating a new
market and
expanding their market share so there is
a difference with a new technology right
and the government's saying okay this
might be beneficial in the long term if
it's a loan that is paid back
which it had been and is creating new
markets because that will actually
create new jobs
that loan allowed tesla to employ more
americans
whereas uh the bailout to gm nine
billion of which
still were on the hook for thanks barack
obama uh actually just
maintains employment and retiree
benefits for people who don't do any
work yeah really really really bad union
so so that is important i think it's
also important you know listen this this
is the result of too big to fail now in
a perfect world no car companies would
be receiving bailouts okay no car
companies are receiving loans
but it's really hard to create a car
company in the 21st century
when uh they're receiving 80 it's just
like you can't create a new airline
right they're receiving hundreds of
millions and billions of dollars over
time
because the government says well they're
too big to fail just like the banks well
what should really happen is the bank
should fail and then local state banks
should become national banks right local
credit unions they should be able to do
a little bit better
the same thing with cars oh you
mismanaged it well
now daewoo gets a shot only in this case
no they've already had this it's tesla
right
it's it's tesla it's really hard to
compete against the big boys just like
opening up a bank you're not going to
compete with bank of america
tesla now people will argue that they've
been more subsidized in the form of a 7
500
tax credit and that is true where for
electric vehicles basically you get a 7
500
tax credit and in a way that's basically
effectively a subsidy but it's different
because it's not just
a one-time bit like 80 billion bailout
right it's basically being subsidized
uh through each car sold because they
see value in this technology
compared to let's say old gas schedulers
now i do i'm against that i am against
that again
0.4 billion dollars and then 7 500 for
cars
here's the thing though here's the
kicker tesla getting 7500 tax credits so
is gm
so support every electric car
manufacturer gets
the 7 500 tax credit so it's not a leg
up from tesla
it's just the same competit the same
level competition field only it's worse
than that
because tesla has actually generated
electric vehicles and this is really
what it comes down to
that people want to buy oh as opposed to
whatever it is the
the volt the bolt there's the bolt in
the boat you think the volt is the
electric but i think the bolt is a
non-electric and the bolt is electric
i don't know what it is there's the leaf
horrible cars they receive
7 500 as well tesla doesn't get any more
because once they sell
200 000 electronic vehicles yeah that
credit goes away
so because tesla has been successful
despite paying back the loan with
interest and gm ford chrysler have not
fully paid back the loan
they've sold 200 000 units and now they
no longer get that subsidy from the
government that tax credit
but gm because they've been making
shitty electric cars that nobody wants
still get that same tax credit so
they're still to this day
receiving more subsidization from the
federal government so i did have to look
at that again
i am totally against bailouts i'm
totally against supporting
and propping up businesses that don't
deserve it in the first place however
you do have to live in the real world
and understand
ultimately since we have given these
ballots is it better or worse for
american consumers and for people who
are working in the american
manufacturing sector
to have another company who can compete
and pay back these loans with interest
and do it on a buy as you go
so that is one thing um that uh i
actually will tell you
has changed my mind on the tesla but you
know the main reason that's good for my
my tesla what was that
on the tesla's uh and i've written tim's
tesla here from hr
my wife actually got you know the gbs
and so um it was really hard it's hard
for her to drive right now
and so i was looking for this sort of
autopilot features and i was looking at
ford and i was looking at the
the korean cars and then i was had to
look uh higher scale where they said
actually the auto driver was really much
better at bmw and mercedes and then
someone said have you really just looked
into a tesla it's not even close
oh wow so i tried driving a tesla it is
it's pretty damn cool it's so so what do
you drive it is
so fun to drive where that wasn't the
case back when it was like i had a
friend who had a prius
he was gay in simi valley uh drove the
priest but i know it's not fully
electric but it was like driving a
shopping cart even with that one fourth
wheel goes
what the hell why can't you get a cart
that works uh compared to the tesla it
is more fun than
any car i've ever driven nice uh and the
autopilot is incredible so it does make
sense to get from my wife you can do the
one pedal driving but even more than
that what convinced me and i want to
know where you line up here on tesla's
uh if this has maybe changed your mind a
little bit or provided some context was
not only did i drive them but when the
hodge twins were here for a week yeah um
i drove with them and uh and so i i
then i i bought one immediately here
you'll see why
[Music]
hodgman's first time on a test uh audio
wade's first time on a tesla too right
got some tesla action going i don't know
if a tesla has exactly
the same zip as a mclaren
but it's pretty
easy on the spaceship
get this thing jonathan down mclaren
we were going 80. what
if you touch the car icon you can
actually turn that zipping this up
bottom left
oh yeah oh was it not uh driving mode
oh you had it you didn't have it turned
up this whole time what's the matter
colonel sanders
chickens so that was slow that was on
slow um
what kind of axles this damn thing got
so look at our axles
should be
yeah i'm about two inches taller
i feel like i got some giraffe action
going oh my god
around my neck
came out
they don't even feel like you on the
ground though people died owning teslas
i mean the thing is like look okay we're
going we're already going 80. yeah
yeah and then you just if i even at the
high gear if i just tap it
all right here let's see i'm going to
get in the lane i'll try the autopilot
and then we'll let you go man i think my
heart's going to beat that moment
we're going to do this again
what do you think i should trust it
going around this curve yeah
i would look like just takes off
that's how the hell it knows to stay in
the lane though
look it's showing me all the cars around
me on the side yeah and see the same
thing it doesn't drive as aggressively
obviously if you uh
right but if i do i think this one does
if i hit the flasher
it says i can't because there's a car oh
son of a [ __ ]
oh that's bryce
we're trying to get to the left lane all
right here you know i'll pull into the
parking lot here
and then uh one of you guys can who
wants to grab the wheel now
look i went eight i went to 75. that was
in three that was in like less than two
seconds
i can't wait till this drill rides over
you wanna drive
i don't trust myself in his car man go
ahead and drive it kevin
you're going to be a lot sick so keith
you're going to drive
are you kevin yeah who said keith was
driving up keith
who's going to drive keith are you
confused come on you know this [ __ ]
happens all the time
hey siri you have [ __ ]
let me see some rear view camera action
you got to do it again
i don't think i said on top
grabbing the road huh yeah i'm liking it
man it feels like i'm flying and getting
sick to my stomach
cops that kind of tells me you're going
to jail
[Laughter]
hey man you going too damn fast man i
just don't even feel like a comment for
like a
let me get some driving action just feel
like some wakanda
grabbing the right i don't know if you
know this but all of africa would be
like wakanda
if not for the united states yeah we
stole all their skyscrapers and
technology on ships
obama did they did
pull it twice yeah pull it twice see the
blue now let go you just kind of lightly
touch the wheel
but you see the blue steering wheel in
front of you yeah that means it's on
no no you put your you want to keep your
hands down lightly i gotta turn this
freaking mute no no it's gonna be good
for us
my heart's beating it lightly touch the
wheel it's gonna natural right
here hit the flasher to go in the left
lane that ain't doing it
i gotta touch the wheel touch with you
i'm just grabbing the wheel all right
if you tap the brake it'll just tap the
brake lightly it'll take off
there you go more autopilot oh
right here hey man what you doing man
you feel that feeling
hey keith man you getting the accident
man being recorded live
[Music]
hey man would you take it easy on the
gas man
i mean on the electricity yeah whatever
it is that's right just they don't run
on gas
big ass duracell i'm gonna go buy me one
of
them
during sale calls
there you go there we go and now you can
let go and it'll ask you to touch the
wheel lightly every now and then
i don't know why this is some robot
action
will it hurt when you will
you ain't asking the right question
that my friend is the right question so
i think it's
i think we just get out i think it'll
turn off
and there you have it uh my mind was
changed i don't know if all of you have
uh
two biracial uh hilarious comedians at
the ready
uh but it helps and i wanna know what
you think with the tesla
uh electric cars in general has any of
this changed your opinion when you
put it in context of subsidization and
the fact that elon musk has created some
really pretty cool
cars and looks like a small child so
elon i hope you enjoy these stock prices
soaring it's entirely
due to this program i've changed my mind
tesla's next installment will be
weed i can already see the comments
coming
[Music]
hey if you like this video be sure to
subscribe if you're already subscribed
hit the notification bell hit all
notifications we have new videos that go
up every day
uh as well as of course an entire show
not available on youtube at
louderworthcredit.com
if you did not like this show please
comment below
uh and address your comments to gerald
be sure to do that also his twitter